mon cartable quelle histoire c'est le
nom du livre dédicacé par abdel aïssou à
versailles le 19 juin dernier 26
personnalités ont participé à cet
ouvrage
amel bent raymond domenech dominique de
villepin ou encore grand corps malade
ces personnalités on raconte un souvenir
d'enfance de leur cartable mais ce livre
est vendu au profit de l'association
le collectif mon cartable connectés qui
permet aux enfants gravement malades
hospitalisés de garder le lien avec leur
classe le livre est vendu 8 euros dont 7
iront directement aux enfants
hospitalisés le collectif et soutenu par
l'association de ladies circle qui
aident à sensibiliser les passants c'est
vrai que l'exclusion que provoque
l'hospitalisation des enfants et quand
extrêmement importante
donc on voit là on leur explique que
c'est un sourire sur le visage d'enfant
que d'acheter ce livre est de permettre
aux cartables connectés de garder
contact avec ses camarades touchés par
cette action de nombreuses personnes se
sont déplacées à la librairie du livre
bleu pour l'occasion
je trouve que c'est une très très bonne
initiative ça permet effectivement de
maintenir le lien avec l'élève c'est
très compliqué pour des élèves qui
s'efforcent on en a en ce moment
actuellement dans notre collège qui gêne
qui suit un traitement très lourd et
malgré tout l'école c'est la vie normale
pour ses élèves
grâce à ces actions d'ampleur nationale
le collectif mon cartable connectés
espère pouvoir aider à l'inclusion de
près de deux millions d'enfants
hospitalisés chaque année